♬SQUEEZIE - PLACEMENTS DE PRODUITS ♬
*Coup de feu*
AH TIC TOC ARRETE ! SORS DE MA TETE !
Les amis aujourd'hui on va parler de cette application je me suis renseigné
mes mort ! Parce que je ne comprenais pas ce phénomène et ça m'énervait de tout mon cœur ! Vous avez failli quitter la vidéo en
me voyant faire un lipsin comme on appelle ça et c'est normal et la dernière fois que vous en aviez vu un c'était sûr
musical.ly et rappelez vous musical.ly,  on en a bouffé de la pub musical.ly à l'époque sur youtube C'était terrible c'est l'appli sur laquelle les
gens chantaient par dessus une musique ou un extrait audio de quelque chose mais avec tellement
d'égocentrisme que ça met 100 % des gens mal à l'aise rassurez vous musical.ly  n'existe plus
C'EST DEVENU TIC TOC ! une entreprise chinoise a racheté musical.ly et à
fusionner les communautés de musical.ly et de tic toc, tic toc étant le musical.ly chinois finalement et ça a donné mec un endroit
où *rires*
je sais pas comment décrire cet endroit généralement les gens s'amusent juste à à
danser et à chanter en se croyant styler cette sur leur musique préférée il y'a quelquefois des trucs innovants qui sont cool à garder et drôle qui
font un peu penser à Vine mais le gros problème c'est la plupart des utilisateurs de tic toc ont entre 10 et 15 ans et
quand tu à entre 10 et 15 ans et que t'as une appli et on te dit vas-y amuse toi et fais des vidéos où tu te crois stylé et ben
tu fais des vidéos qui sont très malaisantes parce que tu as entre 10 et 15 ans et que tu as pas des idées
de ouf ,  il y a qu'à voir
nos premières vidéos à moi ou à n'importe quel autre Youtuber pour comprendre que quand tu es jeune, le contenu que tu fais
c'est pas ouf ! Mais voilà faut pas leur en vouloir à ces enfants qui s'amusent avec tik tok c'est comme ça par contre il faut
pas contre, il faut pas non plus les humilier en faisant des vidéos sur leur gueule en disant regardez comme ils mettent mal à l'aise aujourd'hui c'est pas ce qu'on
va faire il ya plein de problèmes avec tik tok notamment sa entraine du harcèlement c'est entraîne la sexualisation de deux filles ou de mec très très mineurs
mais y'a un truc un truc positif et
incroyable que j'ai vu enfin positif parfois sans insultes,  c'est les trolls mec. Les trolls ont rejoint tik tok. Sur tik tok c'est comme sur
youtube ou ailleurs il y'a des challenges qui ont été créés et donc c'est faire un truc défini sur une musique
définie il y'a par exemple le spooky qui challenge qui consiste à se maquiller en mode je fais peur et chanter par dessus une musique que
je peux pas mettre sinon je vais perdre la monétisation de la vidéo et ça y'en a marre !
Ok ? Les ayants droit là il y en a marre il ya aussi un autre chanel je sais plus le nom désolé ou en gros
c'est quelqu'un qui se confie un peu pendant 12 secondes qui dit des trucs des vérités sur elle même et qui ouvre son coeur et
en fait ce qui s'est passé sur tic tok c'est que tu peux répondre au poste de quelqu'un
et quand tu réponds au poste de quelqu'un
les deux vidéos s'affichent de cette manière là et du coup les gens s'amusent à je sais pas reproduire des danses de fornite en réponse
à quelqu'un qui était en train de dire un truc hyper sincère et
et ça me tue de RIRE !!!!!
brefs regardons tout ça en images vous comprendre pourquoi ça me fait rire où je veux en venir et je vous expliquerai la vidéo
de base de challenge que c'est, pour que  vous puissiez comprendre en quoi le troll est drôle, voilà que vous avez un background. Alors c'est parti alors
ça ça la musique j'ai remplacement au montage par une autre mais sachez que quand c'est cette musique c'est un truc où normalement le mec
fait la première vidéo demande à l'autre de reproduire sa danse et y en a qui sont pas d'accord avec ça et qui répondent en
tapant le téléphone où on s'autant ou à faire n'importe quoi comme ici
*Rires* Ça me tue de rire ! Le mec préfère se flinguer dans les marches plutôt que de reproduire la danse de ce mec torse nu voilà c'est ça qui est chiant avec
tic toc c'est que c'est très très très très très
superficiel tout le monde veut être trop beau monde va être trop stylé et tout le monde veut être une star sur cette appli et
du coup ça fait un peu vomir quoi qu'on y passe du temps Ey il y'a un mec qui sait répondu plein de fois a lui-même et qui
a fait un truc style apparemment oui parce que tu peux répondre à tes propres trucs voilà c'est
Pas mal ! c'est synchro OHH !!! beau gosse
Y'a quand même des mecs qui font des trucs premier degré qui sont innovants et créatifs cool, y a pas que des trucs de merde en vrai
Mes vidéos préférées sont celles où en gros dans le premier encadré il y'a quelqu'un qui fait ça qui fait semblant d'être attirés de l'autre côté
et qui d'un coup accepte et fait un bisou et en gros la personne qui répond doit faire des mouvements synchro pour croire que c'est son bras
qui attire l'autre bon là j'arrive pas à le faire, voila alors voici une vidéo de ce fameux challenge pour vous voyez à quoi ça
ressemble quand c'est réussi moi je peux pas le faire tout seul c'est trop compliqué
Maintenant on va tomber sur quelques dérivés qui me font beaucoup rire. C'est de l'humour noir, attention les gens c'est grave crédible ce qu'il fait
Ouah
*Rires* C'est tellement sexiste que ça me fait rire !!
Ah les mecs ils osent tout ils ont peur de rien c'est fou en vrai l'option de pouvoir répondre à quelqu'un en vidéo et que ca met
deux vidéos côte à côte c'est génial c'est le best truc mec en vrai c'est trop bien
de gens qui le font et qui sont pas du tout des gamers et ça se voit sur la vidéo qui sont pas des gamers
parce qu'ils n'ont pas un casque de gamer ou alors parce qu'ils ont dans les mains comme on vient de voir une manette qui n'est pas
la manette d'une console sur laquelle y'a Overwatch comme cette personne qui a mit une manette de Nes dans ses mains Overwatch n'est
Overwatch ce n'est que sur ps4 ou xbox
elle a un casque
beats sur les oreilles et personne ne joue avec un casque beats donc les mecs l'ont trollé, putain j'explique les trolls c'est incroyable même temps
des fois c'est dur à comprendre les mecs l'ont trollé et du coup en utilisant n'importe quoi comme manette et n'importe quoi comme casque !
Oh c'est pas bien de troller les gens qui prétendent etre gamer alors qu'ils ne le sont pas
en plus ils le sont ils ont déjà joué à Candy Crush une fois c'est sûr. Qu'est ce qu'on a ici ?
Qu'es qu'on a ici ?
*Rires* Ah il s'est fait troll d'une manière incroyable
il y'a des gens qui savent qu'il y'a des trolls qui s'amusent à juste répondre des danses de fortnite à leurs vidéos et du coup
ils se moquent, en disant : " vous le voyez ce gars qui répond  par une danse fortnite c'est un pauvre type
c'est une pauvre merde et lui il  a sorti la carte sens
INVERSE !! UNO ! l'une des armes les plus fortes que l'humanité ait créé mec
AH j'adore ça
les trolls de ce challenge là ça me tue on va appeler ça le bisou challenge à aller puisque je n'ai plus le nom la ! qu'est ce qu'il
lui a répondu clorox
tue 99% des bactéries
*Rires* C'est si méchant !
Cette haine envers les gens qui font les challenge tik tok quelle horreur
AAHH ! Un autre challenge ! et désolé je dois tout vous expliquer mais je veux vraiment que tout le monde comprennent bien les trolls si t'as pas la
ref c'est pas drôle et même pour moi quand j'ai vu c'est trucs la début c'était pas drôle j'avais pas les ref, là c'est
un challenge où en gros tu mets une image tu claque des doigts et du truc avait sur une image tu l'as dans la main et donc à
plein de gens qui s'amusent à troller face à ça. Hop, le Nutella est là, le tic tac là, les oreo
les chips, et le mec à gauche va demander un truc impossible à avoir.
C'est vraiment après cette vidéo que c'est la fin de ma carrière c'est celle là
alors ça j'essaie d'avoir ce que c'est en gros tous les temps tu tapes contre ta came et ta paire de chaussures change
C'est drôle et innovant c'est bien
*Rires* Ah c'est si drôle! J'connaisais pas celle la! Oh Les mecs sont si drôles
*Rires
Les furies c'est des gens qui je crois qu'ils s'amusent à se déguiser en animaux en gros comme ça en animaux mignons sur un tic toc
et qui dansent et y' a plein de gens qui détestent ça et qui répondent comme ça moi je trouve ca cool que ca rassemble des gens qui aiment
la même chose mais ... Ah le fameux challenge j'adore ça !
C'est marrant quand les gens font des parodies un challenge à 2 comme ca c'est marrant ils créent vraiment des histoires avec ça c'est drôle
C'est horrible ça c'est pas du tout drôle
Ca doit être un challenge où les personnes qui n'aiment pas leur corps le montre justement et ses deux petits cons ils répondent en se moquant
comme des gros fils de p*** Ah vous voyez la ca c'est le vrai darkside de tik tok p'tit con la moi je veux leur tirer les oreilles à cela
*Rires* Ils sont drôles !
Les deux en ont marre du challenge mais ils se retrouvent à le faire malgré eux c'est génial ça c'est la bonne utilisation de tik tok
huh c'est quoi cette fois la vanne Ey il y'a l'épaule qui ressort c'est bien fait là
*musique*
quelle est la vanne ?!
AH JE RIS A CA !!
*Choqué*
*musique*
OHHHH !!! C'est au dessus de la ceinture ça compte pas aller hop ça dégage
Mais arrêtez de prendre tik tok au sérieux tik tok ce n'est pas la vraie vie
calmez vous
si vous créez du contenu sur internet vous vous exposez à des critiques c'est normal on s'est tous fait critiquer sur youtube on a tous
pris cher un des moments sur internet c'est comme ça il faut prendre du recul putain les gens ils prennent trop au
sérieux les réseaux sociaux
Ca par exemple c'est horrible
c'est fou mais c'est bien au moins on voit les trucs qui sont horribles ca ca s'attaque physiquement à elle quoi, donc ça me faisait
Zero rire c'est pas drôle du tout au contraire elle a le courage de montrer
son acné qui doit la faire souffrir et se bâtard il répond à ça me fait zéro rire pas drôle
Ca m'abrutis ca m'abrutis une heure de tik tok et je deviens un abruti
Il faut arrêter les gars de faire semblant de se blesser ou de
décéder face à un contenu qui ne vous plaît pas ok ? ça ne vous plaît pas mais ça plaît à des gens mais c'est très
drôle continuez quand même un peu s'il vous plait, enfin pas trop non plus
Les mecs créent une ligue, pour éradiquer le contenu qu'ils aiment pas ! C'est incroyable !
*Rires*
Trop trop de tik tok pour aujourd'hui
je vais m'instruire un peu je vais m'instruire 200 drôle de mots qui ont changé nos vie de Alain Rey a déclaré je vais lire ca un peu
Ce sera mieux que d'aller sur tik tok
BOLOSS
Le destin  ! Bon les amis allez on arrête de s'abrutir j'espère que ça vous a plu
écoutez tik tok prend tellement une ampleur de dingue à 700 millions d'utilisateurs
et pourtant j'ai l'impression que c'est invisible personnes utilisent autour de moi personne ne sait ce que c'est ect... je voulais pas
ignorer ce que c'est en fait alors que ça prend une ampleur incroyable je voulais pas être ignorant vis-à-vis de ça donc je me suis renseigné
et franchement comme j'ai dit à des trolls qui sont drôles il y'a bien entendu beaucoup trop de méchanceté et de
harcèlement aussi sur l'appli et ça c'est dommage, je sais pas si Clément en a laisser mais on a un ou deux j'ai vu passé
c'est ça ma fait zéro rires ou c'était vraiment trop vilain pour la personne et c'était très direct donc c'est horrible
il y'a des truc il faut les prendre du second degré il faut prendre du recul de toute manière d'une manière globale par rapport aux réseaux sociaux en
tout cas si vous allez sur tik tok après cette vidéo et que vous voyez des gens qui font des trucs malaisant il ... juste ignorez ! Mais
ça sert à rien d'envoyer du mal à ces gens là juste ignorons les et si vous voyez une vidéo il ya un potentiel de
réponses qui peuvent être drôle bah répondez de manière drôle sans blesser la personne voilà je suis désolé je fais toujours ces morals un peu
gaga et euphorique en fin de vidéo mais je trouve ça important enfait on peut rire de pas mal de choses mais
blesser vraiment
gratuitement une personne c'est...c'est... c'est con quoi c'est un vrai impact ce qu'on peut faire sur les réseaux sociaux on peut blesser juste avec des
mots ou des actes tout cons juste en répondant à une vidéo où c'est un peu trop direct ce qu'on dit ça peut faire très très
mal à la personne en face faisons gaffe à ça mais en tout cas mec grosse bonne surprise il y'a quand meme des trucs trés drôles
sur tik tok grâce aux trolls et ça me fait beaucoup rire voilà, y'aura peut être une vidéo si les trolls évoluent il ya des
nouveaux codes de nouveau délire qui arrivent là comme les challenge qu'on a vu la, aller en tout cas il est temps d'y aller et
savez-vous ce que je vais faire en passant cette porte ? Passer quatre heures de plus sur tik tok YES !
Merci !!!!
Peace !!